family members of dozens of migrants
killed in a fire at a Mexican detention
facility near the U.S border are
demanding to know why it happened video
from the center shows a horrifying scene
which Mexican officials blamed on the
detainees themselves the Biden
Administration is moving to bring the
injured to the U.S for medical treatment
Jonathan Vigliotti has more on the
tragedy and the reaction
the Anjali Infante screamed in horror as
she found her husband laying inside an
ambulance after a fire ripped through a
Detention Center over the border from El
Paso Texas
inside the center shows a fire in a Cell
officials appear to casually walk away
as the Flames grow and smoke fills the
room at least 38 people died and roughly
30 were injured
Mexico's president said some migrants
set mattresses Ablaze after learning
they would be deported investigators
have not confirmed any other details
many victims family members say before
the fire Mexican police arrested
migrants off the streets and threw them
into the cells
tensions at the border have been high
several weeks ago a large group of
migrants many whom were seeking Asylum
tried to force their way across an
international bridge into El Paso and
just yesterday U.S Homeland Security
secretary Alejandro mayorcas was taken
to task by Republican Senators because
you're the only person in the Milky Way
who believes that we're not having
massive massive illegal immigration into
America there is no question that we
have a very serious challenge a
challenge that has again ended in
tragedy this migrant from Venezuela
blaming the fire on growing desperation
it was one of the biggest causes for
losing control he said for CBS morning's
Jonathan Vigliotti Los Angeles